[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous
bienvenue dans votre recette 8 dans
l'actualité de ce lundi 11 septembre la
ministre des solidarités et des familles
Aurore berger était en visite à Maurepas
samedi dernier pour soutenir les
associations locales parfois en
difficulté à cause notamment du coût de
l'énergie et du manque de bénévole ces
dernières lancent un cri d'alarme et en
cette période de rentrée scolaire
marquée par l'inflation le Lyons club de
Venizi phonique c'est le centre
commercial Westfield Vélizy 2 ont
organisé une collecte de fournitures
scolaires pour les enfants défavorisés
une après-midi de rencontre et
d'échanges et comme chaque lundi nous
parlerons de sport dans votre 7 8 au
programme du baseball avec les Cougars
de Montigny en première division mais
aussi de l'équitation le club hippique
de Versailles s'est refait une beauté
pour les Jeux Olympiques de Paris 2024
et va accueillir l'équipe de Suède en
tant que centre de préparation au jeu
les détails dans cette émission et puis
sans oublier l'invité du 7 8 en deuxième
partie d'émission Michael el midoro sera
avec le maire de Croissy-sur-Seine
Jean-Roger Davin la ville reçoit
l'équipe des Tongas pendant la coupe du
monde de rugby ils ont effectué un
premier entraînement ouvert au public
samedi dernier
[Musique]
le ministère des solidarités des
familles annoncées le déblocage de 156
millions d'euros pour les associations
d'aide alimentaire les associations
caritatives notamment les associations
du don alimentaire vous savez qu'elles
sont très sollicitées parce que
malheureusement on a des Français qui
ont besoin d'avoir recours à l'aide
alimentaire et tout simplement pouvoir
manger des repas qui sont des repas
sains des repas équilibrés c'est aussi
garder sa santé c'est une clé en fait
tout simplement pour pouvoir rebondir
ensuite pour reprendre confiance en soi
un soutien pour les associations d'aide
alimentaire mais d'autres associations
tirent la sonnette d'alarme sur une
problématique que beaucoup partagent le
manque de subventions pour financer un
peu plus les actions que nous menons
parce que par exemple nous avons tout un
travail aussi sur la citoyenneté on
essaye de sortir les personnes qui sont
chez nous de leur secteur quoi parce que
on s'est aperçu que ce sont des gens qui
ne bougent jamais qui ne vont pas au
théâtre qui ne vont pas au cinéma qui ne
qui ne vont jamais visiter quelque chose
et nous on les emmène au musée on les
emmène au théâtre on les emmène au
spectacle au cinéma etc outre l'aspect
financier les associations soulèvent la
difficulté à trouver des bénévoles selon
une étude de 2022 elle comptait 15% de
bénévoles de moins qu'en 2019
attirez les visiteurs une première étape
pour les membres du Lion's Club ce
mercredi 6 septembre ils étaient une
dizaine à se relayer le but distribuer
des flyers et collecter des dons à
destination des enfants démunis en
Île-de-France au Sénégal et en Ukraine
nous avons besoin d'à peu près tout ce
qui se fait en fournitures scolaires de
du taille-crayon
jusqu'au cartable en passant par les
cahiers les gommes les stylos les
feutres une première pour le centre
commercial de Westfield à Vélizy 2 qui
accueille l'événement on a énormément de
partenariats avec des associations
locales avec lesquelles nous travaillons
de façon à pouvoir développer un petit
peu l'état d'esprit du vivre ensemble le
vivre ensemble un état d'esprit partagé
par les consommateurs soucieux de rendre
service il y a tellement de personnes
qui
sont malheureux que bon nous on peut
faire quelque chose donc pourquoi pas je
vais aller chercher des fournitures
scolaires et puis
ça fera ça apprendra un enfant à avancer
et
à apprendre c'est bien
l'association a collecté plus de 4000
euros de fournitures scolaires
[Musique]
dans le reste de l'actualité dans les
Yvelines des actions sont menées pour
venir en aide au sinistre du séisme qui
a sévi au Maroc le 8 septembre dernier
la mosquée de Guyancourt notamment lancé
une collecte de dons en ligne la région
Île-de-France se mobilise avec un fond
d'urgence humanitaire de 500000 euros et
le Secours populaire des Yvelines
débloque un fond de 5000 euros fin des
fortes chaleurs dans les Yvelines après
une semaine de canicule les orages sont
attendus des Mardis 12 septembre mais la
sécheresse est toujours d'actualité le 8
septembre dernier la région sud-est des
Yvelines était placée en situation
d'alerte par la préfecture ce week-end
c'était le forum des associations à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines à Coignières
les habitants étaient au rendez-vous une
quarantaine d'associations étaient
présentes au gymnase du moulin à vent
c'est un moment déjà les associations se
retrouvent et ça c'est quelque chose
d'important de pouvoir se retrouver en
un lieu on touche quand même d'autres
publics notamment nos petites
démonstrations et puis les les nouveaux
adhérents aiment bien rencontrer aussi
nos professeurs donc c'est aussi en plus
de participer à ce forum nos adhérences
sont aussi bien des enfants à partir de
4 ans pour le judo le modelage et alors
la pas de limite d'âge pour les
randonneurs les plus anciens ont plus de
80 ans et voilà
[Musique]
on commence par du rugby la Coupe du
Monde 2023 le Pays de Galles qui a pour
camps de base Versailles pendant
l'épreuve a joué ce dimanche 10
septembre son premier match dans la
compétition ils se sont imposés dans la
difficulté contre les Fidji le score 32
à 26 avec 4 essais les deux côtés
prochain match pour les Gallois samedi
prochain à 17h45 contre le Portugal une
victoire devrait leur permettre de se
rapprocher d'une qualification en quart
de finale en football Versailles arrive
toujours pas dans le championnat de
National les versets n'ont toujours pas
gagné après 5 journées les joueurs de
Laurent peyrela dont une nouvelle fois
concédé le match nul le troisième de
rang à domicile face à Avranches ce
samedi 9 septembre les Versailles
avaient pourtant ouvert le score grâce à
leur star néerlandaise jereman Lens à la
74e minute les Avranches ont recollé au
score à quelques minutes de la fin du
match Versailles 14e toujours en
football le troisième tour de la Coupe
de France est programmé ce week-end
plusieurs équipes divinois sont encore
en lice les principaux matchs à suivre
ou il recevra ce dimanche ouais
Malmaison abri courira 5 louches aussi
recevrez à Ivry Sartrouville ira vitery
trap se rendra à Dourdan en aviron
livinoise claire Beauvais vie
championnat olympique du 2 couple poids
légers raté une première compétition
qualificative pour les Jeux Olympiques
de Paris 2024 la rameuse originaire de
Mantes-la-Jolie sa coéquipière Laura
Tarantola ont terminé 5e de la finale B
elle devront donc passer l'an prochain
par la régate de qualification olympique
de Lucerne pour décrocher un des deux
derniers tickets mis en jeu pour les JO
en VTT la colline d'Élancourt qui va
accueillir les épreuves pendant les Jeux
Olympiques 2024 se préparent pour un
Test Event grandeur nature le dimanche
24 septembre des dizaines de sportifs
internationaux seront présents sur le
site qui culmine à plus de 230 mètres
d'altitude le site sera ouvert après de
3000 spectateurs une belle répétition
pour ce lieu qui va accueillir plus de
15000 personnes pendant les JO
enfin mot de basket pour terminer ce
tour d'horizon de l'actualité sportive
un tournoi amical était organisé ce
week-end sur l'île des Impressionnistes
de Chatou en l'honneur du commentateur
sportif George Eddy victime d'un arrêt
cardiaque en juillet dernier aujourd'hui
remis sur pied l'homme de 67 ans était
présent pour voir ses amis sur les
terrains qu'il a l'habitude de côtoyer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une finale très serrée c'est 9 et 10
septembre les Cougars de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux ont du sanglier
contre les Barracuda de Montpellier à
l'occasion des deux premiers matchs de
la finale du championnat de France de D1
à la sortie de ces deux jours de
compétition les deux équipes repartent
chacune avec une victoire dans leur
valise le samedi Montpellier l'emporte 4
à 3 et le dimanche les inimy montantes
égalisés en gagnant 3 à 2 là on a eu des
opportunités scorées cette fois on les a
pas laissé passer c'est à dire que quand
il y avait des coureurs en position de
marquer on a été chercher les frappes
qu'il fallait pour les faire rentrer et
puis après encore une fois on défend son
a été vraiment vraiment solide
aujourd'hui on a fait des super jeux à
un moment des jeux des jeux défensifs
qui ont été hyper importants pour pour
ne pas laisser Montpellier marquer donc
non non plutôt aujourd'hui tout s'est
bien tous nous à bientôt tout s'est bien
tourné pour nous et c'est cool on repart
avec la victoire maintenant place au
match retour les cougars se rendront ce
samedi 16 et dimanche 17 septembre à
Montpellier pour la suite de ces finales
il faudra gagner les deux matchs sur 3
dans le sud de la France pour soulever
la coupe ça va être un déplacement
compliqué c'est loin il y a du trajet il
fait chaud le terrain il est pas il est
pas il est pas aussi bien qu'ici là-bas
donc ça va être plein de conditions un
petit peu extérieures qui font que des
matchs compliquées mais il faut y aller
un match par un match voilà faire les
petites choses comme on l'a fait
aujourd'hui pensez le moment présent et
puis aller chercher la victoire voilà
mon chat prénom et puis essayer d'aller
au bout si les Cougars de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux l'emporte ce
week-end sur le terrain de Montpellier
ils seront champion de France de
première division pour la première fois
de leur histoire
[Musique]
c'est ici dans cette toute nouvelle
écurie 5 étoiles que le club hippique de
Versailles va accueillir l'équipe
d'équitation de Suède pour les Jeux
Olympiques de Paris 2024 à 10 minutes en
voiture du château de Versailles lieu
des épreuves de sport équestre ce nouvel
espace comprend 8 nouveaux box de plus
de 10 mètres carrés un solarium ainsi
que tout le confort nécessaire pour les
chevaux et les cavaliers alors une
fierté et puis surtout un achèvement
c'est vrai que ça a été beaucoup de
travail pour en être là où on en est
aujourd'hui donc c'est une fierté et en
même temps un réel soulagement pour les
équipes je me suis battue comme une
lionne pour que l'équitation ait lieu à
Versailles parce qu'il y a eu un moment
l'envie de ramener l'équitation à
Lamotte-Beuvron dans le Loir-et-Cher là
où est le siège de la fédération
française j'ai voulu que l'équitation
élu à Versailles parce que l'équitation
à Versailles ça va être waouh on verra
le château en arrière fond de toutes les
épreuves mais je voulais aussi qu'il y
ait un héritage un héritage pour les
Versaillais dans ce club de
Porchefontaine son fils à monter petit
c'est un club familial qui a été par le
passé le club de référence avec des
équipements qui étaient ultra modernes
et qui avait vraiment besoin d'un
sérieux relooking et pour se relooking
le club hippique de Versailles a fait
réaménager sa carrière un nouvel
équipement que le cavalier yvelinois
médaillé de bronze aux Jeux Olympiques
de Tokyo a pu tester avec son cheval
totem de Bresset je trouve que cette
carrière est très bien c'est vrai
qu'elle est très homogène partout il y a
pas de différence de de sol
les carrières subirigé maintenant c'est
vraiment la pointe de la technologie
c'est déjà c'est bien pour les chevaux
parce qu'on a une homogénéité partout et
deuxièmement au niveau de l'économie
d'eau c'est quand même assez flagrant
avec l'aide financière de la Ville de
Versailles du département des Yvelines
et de la région
Île-de-France le club a également pu
construire un manège olympique couvert
un restaurant et un espace de réunion
des conditions idéales pour l'équipe de
Suède qui a récemment les championnats
d'Europe de saut d'obstacles toutes les
équipes étaient les bienvenues il y
avait pas de sélection en termes de
titres ou quoi que ce soit le fait que
ce soit la Suède ben c'est génial parce
que voilà effectivement c'est une nation
majeure en termes d'équitation c'est
chouette qui ne rêverait pas
effectivement en football d'accueillir
l'équipe du Brésil l'équipe d'Allemagne
même l'équipe de France voilà donc
normalement on est content ces nouveaux
équipements resteront après les Jeux
olympiques de Paris 2024 les adhérents
du club hippique de Versailles pourront
les utiliser ce dernier compte 1017
licencier et une centaine de chevaux
demain matin attention nous devrions
avoir des risques d'orage dans les
Yvelines côté température le thermomètre
redescend il fera 18 degrés à Versailles
et Mantes-la-Jolie et 17 degrés à
Rambouillet et aux dents on va pouvoir
respirer demain après-midi les orages
devraient être fini normalement mais
nous devrions avoir quelques averses au
niveau des températures il fera 22
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie et Houdan et 21
degrés à Versailles et Rambouillet et
demain nous fêterons la fin Apollinaire
c'est l'heure à présent de votre 7 8
invité
[Musique]
la Coupe du monde de rugby a démarré
depuis ce vendredi en France et ici dans
les Yvelines on vit aussi au rythme de
la Coupe du monde de rugby et notamment
à Croissy-sur-Seine je suis avec son
maire Jean-Roger Davin bonjour bonjour
Alors Jean-Roger Davin vous vous avez
une équipe qui va rester le temps des
phases de poules c'est les Tongas alors
déjà comment ça s'est passé un peu le
processus pour attirer cette équipe
c'est quelque chose de très long en fait
c'est déjà une notoriété que nous avons
eu parce qu'on a déjà fait des
championnats d'Europe de football on
avait fait aussi la Coupe du Monde
Féminine de avec la France en cambaz ici
donc on a cette expérience on a un stade
qui est magnifique et après ben il faut
essayer comme n'importe quel commercial
d'essayer de récupérer une équipe ici
donc on a travaillé de manière très
forte avec France 2023 et puis au fur et
à mesure des rendez-vous au fur et à
mesure des contacts des visites sur le
terrain on a eu deux trois équipes qui
étaient intéressées et on a terminé par
le Tonga qui pour nous était une très
bonne équipe parce que c'est Pacifique
Sud donc avec des gens qui sont
merveilleux et du coup il y a les
fermescence un petit peu qui monte au
sein de la ville oui bien sûr parce que
d'abord on travaille sur un plan sportif
mais aussi surtout sur un plan culturel
donc les écoles sont bien entendu prises
que ce soit les écoles publiques mais
aussi école municipale de musique la
bibliothèque chez nous avec leur
décompte et puis de cinéma qui se fait
tout autour et puis bien sûr
l'engouement puisque l'équipe de France
a commencé deux manières victorieuse et
donc ça ne peut que porter l'événement
sur notre ville d'accord il y a quoi
précisément qui a organisé dans dans la
ville par exemple des expositions des
choses comme ça alors vous avez une
exposition sur le rugby qui se passe au
château mais vous avez aussi lors des
comptes qui se passait la bibliothèque
et puis tout ce qui va être une
explication sur le Pacifique Pacifique
Sud que ce soit leur religion les
traditions le sport que l'on fait avec
les enseignants des écoles alors il y a
eu une cérémonie hier qui s'est déroulée
ici à Croissy-sur-Seine avec l'équipe
des Tongas est-ce que vous pouvez vous
dire un peu comment ça s'est passé alors
c'est là une cérémonie qui a pu
officielle on ne peut absolument déroger
à rien c'est ce qui se passe dans le
rugby c'est le monde Anglet Saxon donc
vous avez deux grandes parties dans
cette cérémonie une première étape qui
est les discours des officiels donc en
fait vous avez quatre personnes qui
parlent le maire France 2023 la wordre
rugby et puis généralement une autre
personne qui peut-être un président du
Conseil du Sénat un premier responsable
de de conseil régional et puis ensuite
vous avez la vraie cérémonie officielle
ce qu'on remet les caps comme on dit
donc en fait les casquettes avec une
médaille et ce qui permet à un joueur
d'être identifié comme ayant fait une
coupe du monde de rugby puisque s'ils ne
sont pas dans les trois premiers ils ne
recevront pas une médaille ils pourront
montrer leurs caps et leur médailles de
participation qu'on leur a donné au
départ donc pour eux très important et
très émouvant c'est la première fois que
vous voyez vous cette équipe des Tonga
non ils sont on les a reçu ici le 5
septembre on les voit régulièrement
s'entraîner sur notre salle mais une
manière officielle ils nous ont fait le
bonheur de nous faire un entraînement
ouvert samedi 9 et puis le la cérémonie
officielle dimanche on va écouter
justement un membre du staff de Tonga
c'est un bon endroit nous aimons
beaucoup
on a déjà eu un super weekend ici et
c'est parfait bon hôtel une belle petite
ville il fait juste un peu chaud
on a tous ce que l'on a besoin on a une
piscine de terrain une salle de sport
une salle de réunion intérieure le
terrain est de classe internationale et
il y avait également beaucoup de
supporters qui étaient présents pour
cette cérémonie et bien plus de 1000
personnes ce qui pour nous est quelque
chose de très important alors
effectivement on aurait peut-être pu en
avoir plus il faisait très très chaud
très très lourd c'est un peu difficile
mais en même temps on se plaint toujours
parce qu'il fait très chaud mais s'il
avait plu il aurait eu personne donc
dans c'était excellent très très bien
beaucoup d'engouement beaucoup d'enfants
ont fait tout ce qu'il nous faut pour la
ville de Croatie c'est l'occasion aussi
de créer du lien entre une population
étrangère peut-être et des habitants de
Croissy-sur-Seine alors vous savez qu'à
Croatie on a plus de 10% une population
qui est de l'angle anglo-saxonne mais
c'est aussi une coupe du monde de rugby
c'est vous recevez des jeunes pour
recevez des athlètes donc ça permet à
nos jeunes de pouvoir voir non plus à
travers la télé et un écran mais de visu
ce que c'est qu'un sportif de haut
niveau ça permet de décaler et de
montrer à tout le monde que ce qu'elles
sont les valeurs de sport et puis aussi
l'amitié entre les peuples et là de
découvrir un nouveau peuple qui habite
très loin donc il y a le Pacifique Sud
avec des traditions comme les maorilles
les walysies donc c'est très important
de pouvoir l'expliquer à nos jeunes le
regard des enfants il était comment hier
en fait c'était pas hier qu'il fallait
venir c'était samedi quand vous étiez
sur le stade avec une équipe qui joue le
jeu une équipe qui donne des maillots
qui a fait bien entendu des interviews
et qui ont donné des signatures donc ça
les enfants étaient très très intéressés
mais un peu avant ils ont fait un
entraînement un vrai entraînement et là
vous voyez la vitesse et laquelle ça va
la lecture des chocs et le bruit des
chocs que vous avez entre le rugby donc
en fait vous le voyez sur place quoi on
va écouter justement un supporter qui
était à présent sur place hier c'est une
équipe très sympa et avec un qui propose
un beau jeu donc c'est un plaisir de les
voir ici quoi je sais qu'il y a ben qui
joue pas à Toulouse
qui joue très très bien aussi ils ont
une belle équipe et je leur souhaite
d'aller plus loin possible du coup c'est
quoi la suite pour cette équipe des
tongs Galles va rester un mois c'est ça
à peu près ici à quoi ça sur moi d'abord
elle va faire son premier match à Nantes
samedi
alors les Tongas la malchance qu'ils ont
c'est qu'ils sont dans la poule de la
mort
Afrique du Sud Irlande et causes donc ça
c'est dans les cinq premiers mondiaux et
eux ils sont classés autour de la 15e
place mais pour autant on y croit c'est
une équipe du Sud donc ils sont un peu
fantasques et il peut faire des très
très belles choses d'abord c'est une
équipe de Koso c'est pas des des rigolos
puisque sur 10 coupes du monde ils ont
été présents sur les 8 premières donc
vous voyez toujours présent à l'appel
bon ils ont fait des bons résultats
aussi en sélection donc il y a pas de
raison qu'on n'est pas une surprise en
tout cas on espère une surprise dans la
mesure où bien entendu il bat pas
l'équipe de France ou surtout en finale
vous avez un petit pronostic ou pas vous
espérez quand même qui passe les poules
j'imagine oui on pense que ça va être
très dur ils ont de fortes chances de
gagner contre la Roumanie peut-être
contre les causes parce qu'on les a vu
un peu en difficulté ce week-end après
l'Irlande et l'Afrique du Sud ça va être
très difficile vous les avez vu un petit
peu à la salle de sport
chez nous et dans notre gymnase beaucoup
bien sûr beaucoup de musculation et
après des phases en action bon là ils
sont en train de répéter leurs gammes
ils font pas vraiment de la muscu c'est
pas la préparation physique dure comme
avant les sélections là ils sont en pro
match donc forcément un peu moins
intense mais surtout dans les tactiques
ils regardent à la vidéo ce qui se passe
dans l'équipe qui vous rencontrez et ils
essaient d'appliquer les techniques et
les tactiques qui vont mettre en place
c'est pour ça que les entraînés les
entraînements sont fermés et qu'on peut
malheureusement pas faire venir plus de
personnes et comment ça va se passer
après pour la suite admettons que ton
gars soit éliminé à l'issue des phases
de poules comment ça va se passer ici
pour pour la suite alors jusqu'au 4
octobre on a les Tongas il joue leur
dernier match le 7 et ensuite on a été
aussi sélectionné
centre sur la région Île-de-France pour
pouvoir faire les phases finales donc je
vous rappelle qu'il y a deux quarts de
finale qui vont se passer au stade de
France les deux demi-finales et les deux
finales perdant et gagnants et donc à
chaque fois on aura la possibilité
d'avoir une des quatre équipes ou des 8
équipes qui seront présentes ici et qui
viendront éventuellement dans notre
salle donc le choix est assez facile
c'est le premier qui choisit son stade
mais je ne je n'ai pas d'inquiétude
dessus en étant à peine à 15-20 minutes
du Stade de France en ayant des
installations sportives et surtout une
pelouse audière de France 2023 qui est
une des meilleures en ce moment donc il
y a pas de problème on aura des gros ici
et on pourra éventuellement si on peut
faire un entraînement ouvert pour
montrer ses équipes au fond de vous vous
aimeriez avoir quelle équipe aucune
elles sont toutes bonnes peut-être les
néo-Z s'il reviennent alors l'équipe de
France je pense qu'il resteront à Rueil
mais que ce soit l'Afrique du Sud que ce
soit l'Australie que ce soit
l'Angleterre ou le Pays de Galles ou
l'Irlande il y a absolument aucun
problème on va terminer peut-être par un
pronostic pour l'équipe de France enfin
sur l'équipe de France pour ceux qui
veulent aller loin cette équipe de
France bah écoutez poule ça peut être
aussi une belle fête à quoi c'est sur
scène c'est une victoire on vous l'a pas
dit mais on retransmet tous les matchs à
l'auditorium
mais après pour B c'est les 5 meilleurs
mondiaux qui sont là donc il va falloir
se retrouver en quart de finale ça ça
devrait pas poser de problème et si on
sort des quarts de finale je pense qu'on
sera champion du monde j'aimerais bien
avoir un match retour entre France et
Nouvelle-Zélande avec là aussi encore
une victoire de la France Merci
Jean-Roger Davin et vous l'aurez compris
il est ton gars seront ici pendant un
mois à Croissy-sur-Seine
[Musique]